queen of all trades from her time as a
WWE Superstar to her charity work to her
new movie Strawberry princess she does
it all and it's a thrill to have her in
studio with us welcome to the show thank
you for having me you're not alone I
know I have glitter here glitter a
little glitty that was glittery 12. 12
years old yeah so she's my old little
lady oh she is adorable and happy
belated birthday to you thank you how
was your birthday weekend celebration it
was it was good super chill just did
dinner and kicked my feet up it's like
nice when you can just relax if you're
like ah and you're a Scorpio a Scorpio
do you follow all the astrology and all
those things I do and I definitely feel
like I am my sign yeah a little feisty a
little sassy a go-getter so yeah well we
saw that little feisty little sassy in
your time in the WWE going back to that
looking back on that what are some of
your fond memories from your time as a
as a WWE Superstar it also has a diva to
it and your fans fell in love with you I
fell in love with you watching on WWE
thank you um you know it one of my best
moments I guess you can say is like
WrestleMania you know that's the Super
Bowl so being there my first year on the
road being with Brodus and Naomi and
yeah
so definitely you know some great great
memories just everything working with
Special Olympics and the whole nine and
you keep growing and scaling in your
life uh you're always growing doing new
things the movie Strawberry princess I
was watching the trailer telling
everyone about the movie because it
looks really good yeah so strawberry
Princess
um I probably wouldn't get in trouble if
I said that but she pretty much does
what she needs to do to like fight for
her son and make ends meet so I had to
play a lot of different characters that
which I felt like wow okay you know I
can do this like you know let's go move
it from WWE to be now the female version
of the rock yeah absolutely someone's
got to do it why not you yes exactly and
your your app to the app is the double A
Academy I downloaded it I love the app
did you show people different exercises
things to do we'll show it on the screen
right here I was looking at this your
leg exercises to do tell us more about
the app yeah so you know I feel like we
live in such a crazy world where there's
so much noise
um and my app just it doesn't just get
you physically fit it gets you mentally
fit um I have ADHD depression anxiety so
for me it was super important to create
an app that focuses on your mindset
um and yeah just it's it's for anybody
beginner intermediate Advanced and yeah
just walk you and take you to school of
getting a mental and physical shape and
it's also to just about living a healthy
lifestyle and because I do have ADHD
depression I like to use things like
Boomer just I don't just to get my mind
filled with goodness yes because the
world's crazy it certainly is yeah and
you have recipes on there and then
you're kind of like your life motto of
building your own door I'm big on
expanding your mindset tell us more on
that too yeah you know I think if you
sit here and you wait for someone to
give you an opportunity you'll be
waiting to the day you die so I always
say like create your own door and make
it happen because no one's gonna do it
for you I mean yes I come from WWE but
there's so many things I love doing and
I don't want to dream to live at the
cemetery you keep going just keep going
I love it thank you so much for joining
us all right we appreciate it thank you
and also glitter yes little glitty over
here thank you so much we appreciate it
and uh have fun when you're in Vegas
they get a birthday week celebration I I
did enough of that this weekend I'm I'm
like I'm I'm dying yeah all right
Jillian we'll send it over to you all
right we'll give back this holiday
season how you can get involved with the
just one project plus details on their
new campaign